summer hasn't troubled the North
Atlantic this year the seas are rough
and visibility low to non-existent
it's a bad time to launch an
international search and rescue mission
crew members of the submersible Titan
left this port just a few days ago now
the operation to save them will be based
from the same facility
and the leader of Newfoundland said it
won't be easy we've had one of the worst
Springs in on record the worst spring
since 1943 which of course is is bad
enough being on land it's absolutely
terrible being 600 kilometers off our
shore as we're talking you know 12 foot
waves a heavy fog very difficult search
and rescue conditions these pictures of
the submersible were taken moments
before it began its descent
an experimental vessel made from carbon
fiber and titanium the owner said it
could monitor the strength of its Hull
in real time one hour and 45 minutes
later the support team lost contact
and at a press conference in Boston the
U.S Coast Guard said the vessel has
still not been located good afternoon
these search efforts have focused on
both surface with C-130 aircraft
searching by sight and with radar
and subsurface with P3 aircraft we're
able to drop and monitor sonar buoys to
date those search efforts have not
yielded any results
the names of all five crew members on
the Titan are now known
British Adventurer Hamish Harding is
joined by the owner of the submersible
Stockton Rush prominent Pakistani
businessman shazada diode and his son
Suleiman are also on board both hold
British citizenship
and we understand French explorer Paul
orri najalay of referred to as Mr
Titanic is also on the vessel a close
friend said he knew the risks but we
knew this was going to happen at some
point along the way
and knew darn well it would and we knew
all the difficulties there would be
about how do you recover from that if
the sub is stuck on a shipwreck if they
lose batteries if they're caught on the
bottom some other way and nothing was
done about it
the weighty responsibility of a deep sea
rescue now belongs to the governments of
two Nations and a host of private actors
they've seen tragedy on the high seas on
this island before and they've mounted
complex rescue efforts from here as well
but no one not the Americans not the
Canadians have been involved in an
operation like this not at these
distances and not at these depths
the premier and the people of this
province have offered their prayers and
they know that time is running out John
Sparks Sky News Saint John's
Newfoundland